Hey Youtubers happy Super Bowl new guardians let's
break it down awesome thing here is I think
that we are looking at ego the living planet
in the background of the shot.
So just because so much awesome stuff is happening.
There's a new round of the Marvel giveaway.
There's a new Spider-Man action figure this
crazy articulated so that's what the giveaway
is for all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this video
be sure to click that bell to enable alerts
so you don't miss anything.
So for the most part we get to meet all the
other big characters of the movie.
We get to meet Ayesha who's actually name
is kismet in the comics so I'm just going
to go through this shot by shot you see the
guardians standing in the audience chamber
of kismet she's the leader of this genetically
engineered perfect people in the comics she
was created by the enclave just the ability
to manipulate cosmic energy she is functionally
immortal.
So he basically this perfect being.
So I don't know how literally they did that
for the movie she might not have the ability
to wield cosmic powers, but the way James
Gunn talked about her she sounds like she's
the leader of the super uptight peoples, the
higher the guardians to get rid of this monster
and things go sideways.
Originally the idea is that she was created
by the enclave this in a beehive of scientists
to be a clone of Adam warlock she's like a
female version of Adam warlock which is why
she looks like this so if they never do Adam
warlock in the movies.
You can think of at least they did a gold
version of a character that's very similar
to Adam warlock.
So just look out for Easter eggs for him whenever
they have scenes with her the way they cut
the trailer they jump around a lot.
You see tracks jump down in the middle of
that sentence of hers like who the hell do
you think you are well aware the guardians.
So this planet that he's on the you see throughout
the trailer looks like ego the living planet.
This is a big wide shot of that so it looks
exactly like him in the comics but we know
he Star Wars father, and he made himself a
human body that is played by Kurt Russell,
so they haven't fully explain how that's gonna
work.
He doesn't appear in the trailer that I do
think that were seeing ego the living planet
in his planet form you see Yandu here co-piloting
the Milano with star Lord then later in the
trailer baby Groot and rocket formally invite
him to the guardians.
He said welcome to the guardians only he didn't
say Frick and if you're not a big Fleetwood
Mac fan.
The song was playing in the background is
called the chain the cool thing about this
is that this is my fraternity song in college.
So this has some special significance for
me but the song itself is all about the idea
of family keep the chain together keep the
family together in this context of just talking
about this new guardians team in the family
has grown.
You finally see nebula wearing Ravagers guardians
looking uniform.
So we don't know how long she's going to be
with them, but she is going crazy Karen Gillan's
going to be amazing.
I love this montage of Gomorrah to her holding
one of rockets mega giant guns, he just has
like the biggest guns ever as part of the
comedy of his character is that the smallest
creature has the biggest weapons the cool
thing about that if you really happy about
rocketing Groot in the film is that James
Gunn is talked about the third film actually
not being a direct sequel being more of a
Groot rocket spinoff film that of the CG of
Yandu spend it looks way cooler in this movie
in they obviously did the comic books in the
big one.
The way James Gunn explained it is that he
just had a different version.
The first movie in in this movie when the
ravages revolt against them.
Yes to have baby Groot help him get the fin
so that he can control the arrow, and help
break them out.
So I like the way that we saw this without
the extra CG and earlier trailers with everybody
just flying around in 0G and now we know what's
going on is like a bigger version of that
scene from the first movie regatta just takes
all those dudes down with the arrow a little
more manta speaking out on baby Groot oh he's
so cute I love the moment with her later in
the trailer which he just gets taken out by
the debris and directors like sorry sir a
try guys haven't said too much about what
role she's going to play going forward, but
she's going to be in infinity war, she was
one of the people that was confirmed by 40
done a video for that.
So well at a link at the end of this, so she's
going to be a really big character even though
we haven't seen that much of her this is probably
my new favorite shot of nebula, and just look
at the colors in the background to you just
have to appreciate the way James Gunn makes
a frame one of the best things about guardians
was its color palette just the way he painted
those images even though I'm sure the stories
going to be really amazing for this movie.
The characters will be great is going to look
amazing.
This right here is taserface he sort of like
the new leader of the Ravagers after they
revolt against Jon do the character them way
back in the comics he's a deep cut.
James Gunn explain the joke from before the
first movie came out.
That led to him being part of this film.
So originally he was in anywhere in these
movies, but James Gunn always likes to make
jokes paperlike was that it be in the first
guardians movies.
This is a couple years ago he was just joking
around he threw a fake spoiler out there that
said taserface come to now he's actually put
them in this movie.
So he just a big bad ass in the classic guardians
comics the one where Yandu is on the team
hero shot see they keep going back to this
planet.
I keep thinking that this is ego the living
Just based on the look of all this organic
material behind them.
Let me know what you guys think of the trailer
so far I'm not expecting to see Kurt Russell
himself maybe till the last trailer they kind
of did that with vision during the Avengers:
Age of Ultron trailer.
They did that was Spider-Man during the last
Captain America Civil War trailer.
So what will probably happen next is of the
release a longer version of this they'll explain
a little bit more about the story beats with
some more finished CGI so you look at the
earlier trailers, and there's some repeated
footage like the on two stuff just has a bunch
of extra stuff that they've added since they
started finishing all that stuff is going
to be editing the movie till right up until
they release it.
So there still footage that isn't finished
yet, but they have plenty for budget trailers.
A lot of you are asking about Thanos infinity
gems I don't think that James Gunn is said
anything about the infinity gems that he did
say that there was no Thanos in the film and
he's not lying he's not misleading people
so if Thanos shows up.
It will be in Thor Ragnarok not in this movie.
So we can start speculating about what this
Post credit scene is going to be because Thor
Ragnarok is the next movie.
After this, not including Spider-Man, but
it's more likely that this movie would have
connected tissue with Thor, just because they're
both in outer space.
So let me know in the comments.
If you have any requests for special bonus
videos on characters I'll probably do ego
the living planet video tomorrow.
I want to do a Groot videos to but as for
Spider-Man, or other trailers.
I'm not expecting any other Marvel footage
this weekend but like they drop that Justice
league teaser picture there might be some
more stuff like that from the other studios.
So I'll be posting more Super Bowl trailers
is that we can gets on this going to be some
stranger thing season 2 so.
Just look out for that later tonight while
you wait for that you can click here to learn
about the guardians that are confirmed for
infinity war and you can click here for more
Super Bowl trailer.
Thank you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see in the next video!